البديل البرازيلي ، المملكة المتحدة ،
البديل الجنوب أفريقي ، ما
الذي نحتاج إلى معرفته حول كل هذا
جيدًا ، أنت تعرف أم تراقب
كل هذه الأشياء ، أعني أنك
تعرف الآن إذا كنت تفكر في هذه
المتغيرات
ككل المناطق التي هم  تتم إعادة تطوير
هذه الطفرات حول بروتين سبايك ،
وهو شيء
تحدثنا عنه لبعض
الوقت.الأجسام المضادة التي تولدها
هذه اللقاحات
التي توفر نوعًا ما
غطاء فوق البروتين السنبلة ،
لذا نأمل أن يستمروا
للعمل إذا كان هناك المزيد من الطفرات
أو أنها تحدث في مناطق
أخرى بعيدة عن بروتين سبايك الذي
قد يكون مشكلة ولكن أريد أن أتحدث
عن البرازيل واحدة لثانية
وهذا
يسمى متغير p1
جاء من منطقة  يُطلق عليهم اسم ماناس في
البرازيل والسبب في
أهميته هو أنه كان يُعتقد
أن كل شخص هناك
قد أصيب في وقت ما من
العام الماضي بفيروس كورونا
ثم رأوا عودة ظهور الحالات
وهذا نوع من ما
أدى إلى التحقيق في
ما يحدث هنا عندما نظروا في
هذه الحالات الجديدة
وجدوا أن بعضها كان من
هذا النوع الجديد ، لذلك كان هناك أشخاص أصيبوا
مرة أخرى بالعدوى وكان هناك
زيادة في قابلية الانتقال
والآن كما أشرت ، هناك
مريض واحد على الأقل
في مينيسوتا عاد من
البرازيل تم
اختباره في التاسع من كانون الثاني (يناير) ، لذا منذ بعض الوقت
وقد عاد ذلك الآن باعتباره
إيجابيًا
لهذا البديل ، لذا فإن البديل
يتحرك وهذا ليس  من المفاجئ
أنه يبدو أنه أكثر قابلية للانتقال
وأكثر عدوى
وهذا ليس مفاجئًا أيضًا أن هذه
الطفرات تسمح لهذه الفيروسات
بدخول الخلايا بسهولة أكبر
ولكن على الأقل في الوقت الحالي يبدو أنها
محمية ضد اللقاحات الموجودة
ولكننا "  سنراقب ذلك
إذا استمعت عن كثب إلى الدكتور أنتوني
فوسي ، فستبدأ في سماع لغة
حول المتغيرات التي تعتبر شيئًا
مثيرًا للقلق  لي أنه من المجهول ، فإن احتمال
أن هذه المتغيرات يمكن أن تتفوق على ما
نحن فيه في اللقاحات التي تجعل
الأطباء قلقين في هذه المرحلة ، ما
الذي تسمعه ،
نعم أعتقد أن هناك شكلين
لمجرد أن
شيئًا ما أكثر قابلية للانتقال بينما
لا يكون أكثر فتكًا
وهو ما يبدو أنه هو الحال
مع هذه المتغيرات ، فهذا لا يعني
أنه لا يمثل مشكلة
لأنه إذا بدأت في إجراء العمليات الحسابية
ونظرت إلى شيء أكثر قابلية
للانتقال بنسبة 50 في المائة ،
فهذا يعني أنك تعرف أن المواجهات غير الرسمية
الناس الذين أفلتوا
بسبب عدم نشر
الفيروس سيصبحون أكثر إشكالية ،
أعني إذا كنت مجتهدًا في
ارتداء قناع ، فلا يزال يتعين عليك أن تكون على ما يرام
ولكن بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين كانوا
أكثر إهمالًا ، فهم كذلك  سيكون لديك
مساحة أقل للمناورة للإصابة
بالعدوى والشيء الآخر هو أن
السكان المعرضين للخطر هم أكثر عرضة
للإصابة بالعدوى في الواقع إذا أجريت العمليات
الحسابية
في غضون شهر  إذا كان لديك فيروس أكثر قابلية
للانتقال مقابل فيروس أكثر فتكًا ،
فسيظل الفيروس الأكثر قابلية للانتقال
يؤدي إلى المزيد من الوفيات لأنه من
المرجح أن يؤثر على الفئات الضعيفة من
السكان ، فهذه هي المشكلة الأولى والمسألة الثانية
مرة أخرى هي هذه الطفرات
بشكل عام من حيث اللقاح
الشيء المثير للاهتمام هو أنك
لا تريد زيادة عدد اللقاحات فقط ، بل
تريد زيادة وتيرة
التطعيمات لأنه
كلما زاد انتشار
الفيروس ، زاد عدد الطفرات التي يراكمها
لن تكون طفرات كبيرة
ولكن  إذا لم تبدأ في تراكم
الطفرات التي تجعلها أكثر
مقاومة للقاح
، فهذه مشكلة أخرى
وهذا هو السباق
الذي تحدث عنه دكتور فوسي نوعًا ما